this is downtown Kiev University
buildings consulates embassies it's
about a civilian as you can get now the
cleanup has already got rid of much of
the destruction but when the Missile hit
it was Monday morning Rush Hour people
going to work in their cars were caught
up in The Inferno and this is just one
of several such sites around the city I
asked the tally Klitschko kievs mare for
his response what Russians did
is genocide of your grand population
they need Ukraine without ukrainians and
we have a lot of numbers
people who died today civilians and
civilian infrastructure careful of
Ukraine peaceful City they threatened
more attacks so what's the message to
residents of Kiev should they be scared
he capital of Ukraine was Target and
steal Target from Russians and that's
why please pay attention if you listen
the
warming
attack please go to the bunkers not
since the start of the war has this city
suffered such an onslaught for months
people have been ignoring the sirens
because they thought that the danger had
passed well Monday feels very very
different and the question is will
Vladimir Putin be good on his word that
there's more to come